welcome back to las vegas now march is
colorectal aware colorectal cancer
awareness month so we caught up with
nevada surgery and cancer care to learn
more about screenings
and of course prevention take a look
march is national colorectal cancer
awareness month
there are about at least 150 000
colorado cancer developed
each year in the country 90 of
colorectal cancer
is completely curable if we screen them
early your family history
your ethnicity play a major role in this
colon cancer health health aspect there
are many tests available
that you can use the two common
tests right now we use our colonoscopy
and a test called color guard everybody
heard about colonoscopy
and know about it it's a endoscopic
examination meaning
i will place the person in sedation
and when you're asleep i place a camera
inside your colon
and visually inspect the colon and if
there's
any abnormality like polyps or growth
that can be removed
so it's a test that is invasive but on
the other hand
the test will be able to remove any
abnormalities that detect it
so in a way it's a test that is
preventive to prevent future cancer it's
also
a test that is therapeutic
that can remove any potential
issues for the future there are people
that
are uncomfortable or afraid taking their
prep work for the colonoscopy
the prep is not pleasant you have to
drink certain
uh medications make you go to bathroom
to clean out all
the residual stew in your colon so we
can have a good inspection
we will work with you to make the prep
as
less uncomfortable as possible so we can
give you a good examination
and you can have your colon health
checked and guaranteed
cologar is a test that's developed by
mayo clinic
if the purpose of that is it's
non-invasive
it's convenient it can be done at home
the
test comes with a kit that after you
discuss with your doctors
the kit will be sent to your home there
are instructions
in the test kit they're pretty
straightforward to follow
you send your proof samples back to the
company
the company will look at it in their dna
analysis
and they will send a yes or no scores to
your doctor's office
then you will discuss with the doctor if
the test came back
as good then you are essentially
clear of the cancer risk for the next
several years you do not need to go out
to do a colonoscopy
and if the test shows some questions
then a colonoscopy will be ordered to
make sure
there's no polyp or cancerous growth in
your body our practice mission
is provide personalized individual cares
to make it easier for you to go through
this difficult time
take the anxiety away from you so you
can focus on your illness
and your health and recover and continue
your life enjoy with your family
contact nevada surgery and cancer care
at 702-739-6467 or visit
nvscc.com